et bien alors raymond oliver aujourd'hui
on perd pas si je comprends bien il a
envoyé jeu si bon soir eh bien voyez je
voulais aller assez vite parce que je
voudrais mettre à cuire la confiture que
je suis en train de confectionner
comment génocide ou son frère
eh bien oui oui l'amour fait se fera
avec de la confiture ou alors commenté
les premiers épisodes de cette confiture
miel bio 500 g de fraises que je suis en
train de passer au tamis ses 100 grammes
à la chambre il faudra obtenir 500
grammes d'obtenir 500 grammes
après avoir été passé c'est à dire si sa
maman environ une fois décortiqué s'il
avait aussi exclusivement les à huy sur
compte toujours un tout petit peu de
l'éperon il faut qu'il va faire bon ben
voilà savoir 2 h et passe comment ça
s'appelle le curé janot p nous sommes
montés feu rouge alors voilà c'est bien
ceux ci étant terminée je m'en
débarrasse deuxième opération le
remettre sur le feu le plus violent
possible car nous voulons que ça évite
donc il faut que c'est pour aller vite
ou bien c'est nécessaire non non non ce
n'est pas un jeu sur la recette on
pourrait faire il conclure le
m'atteindre empilement et puis vers le
camp au soir non non c'est uniquement
parce que je peux de temps
rien n'est dit quelque
chose dans votre casserole il n'y a
absolument rien pour le moment qu'elle
souhaitait simplement son léger ans
alors je vais maintenant 500 g de sucre
pour 500 g de purée sais pas si je
compose je mets la pression qui le tour
selon la cuisson à bien écouter nous
allons aller le plus vite possible
puisque nous avons la possibilité
nous avons des gars ça marche vite et
nous allons gagner peut-être 5 6 minutes
sur le temps normal je crois que ça sera
fait en 2008 le 10 minutes en dix
minutes un quart d'heure mais à partir
de quel moment est-ce que ça va être
venir
la mousse aux fraises qui est annoncée
parce que jusque là nous en sommes à la
fois si tu es bien à la fin tout à faire
affaire lorsque tout sera composé nous
on fait notre préparer notre gâteau
notre gâteau en quelque sorte à une
mousse aux fraises parce que forcément
ça sera fait uniquement avec des fraises
derrière et du sud pour faire une mousse
d'habitude hommes et des jeunes oui oui
jean baptiste non non pas du tout non
non c'est pas un truc du tout nous
mettons d'ailleurs 2
des blancs d'air tout à l'heure alors
voyez vous ici j'attends que ça parte se
fasse un nom au début ça va gonfler
normes et masaya sera doublée volume
d'affaires un petit peu comme le lait
sur le feu
et c'est pour éviter que salam déborde
que je fais attention je leur mue mais
une fois que ce premier mouvement de
gagner à l'évolution cette espèce de
tentatives de nous échapper la le
cloître en futur sera passée alors la
[ __ ] et aucun indice que nous pourrons
laisser tout doucement c'est là qu'il
faut faire vraiment d'une très grande
sourire c'est ça au départ canon ce
plage qui est dessus on pourrait le
cumin center partisans tout les
confitures c'est qu'une derrière et dans
les vieux procédé on faisait les
confitures tout doucement ce qui est
d'ailleurs été certainement très très
bien aujourd'hui nous avons un petit peu
modifié parce qu'on aura dans les cinq
étapes où et même sa vie aux voyages aux
îles et n'annonce en rien les gens que
je sens que je le tiendrai vous ça ira
tout seul jusqu'à isoler un tout petit
peu ça sortira vers marc meilleur je
vous dis j'ai donc tout à l'heure que
nos sucre sont beaucoup plus forts que
les sucres qui était employé autrefois
et de ce fait là
nous n'aurons pas besoin de voir mêmes
précautions élémentaires attention une
question de raffinage c'est une question
de raffinage au combien de temps alors
là vous allez tout de même le laisser à
passer du tout normalement je vais
laisser pleins feux tout à fait tout le
temps et les avenants bien l'attention
événement rivaux ce que je vais le faire
de ne pas laisser dévorer ce que la
règle est d'ailleurs un tout petit peu
peut-être je vais être obligé de pécher
peut-être un tout petit peu le feu ça
c'est bien poursuivre vous avez du gaz
dans fable à mais justement c'est
tellement facile à régler que je n'aurai
pas de difficultés mais ça va très très
bien
effectivement et vous savez un tout
petit peu fort je vais donc mais c'est
un tout petit peu quitte à revenir très
vite tout à l'heure sur la fin de la
cuisson
donc voilà et bien maintenant dans une
casserole en cuivre ses préférences
oui toujours c'est toujours préférable
pour faire les confitures de l'effet a
directement dans les cuivres
ce n'est pas une espace est
indispensable m'avait c'est toujours
mieux
alors là vous connaissez le bol à blanc
la bassine à blanc mollahs blanc va
senna blanc elle là je me suis brûlé ses
rivaux les petits bruits mais ces gens
évoluent at-il qui ne font pas mal en
quelques heures
elle ne bloquera pas où je me suis brûlé
les toucher le sais parce que c'était
tellement chaud que ça ne m'a pas volé
alors voyez vous ici je mets environ 2,6
à le sida bible en mettons cette pour
être mieux
oui ça fait cher alors là je vais le
salé laisse aller c'est blanc fait les
seules assez peu mais enfin laissant
tout de même un taux d'is le cic pour
éviter qu'il ne grève pas passer les
opérations doit se taire
au début elle voudrait pas faire
beaucoup de bruit parce que les blancs
doivent être battus sans toucher pour le
vol et surtout les blancs comme un seul
corps
[Musique]
les exigences et bien c'est difficile
ici mais attend d'y monter en
température là bas qui proviennent en
fait due à la foudre qui te fait vite si
vous voulez gère qui rend tout moment à
passer comme ça ces trois palais sera
pas très long d'ailleurs vous pourrez
les montées avec makelele dit souvent et
le procès qui prévaut crise éclate dans
mes droits je sois là il faut savoir se
servir de demain j'entends déjà parce
que je vois une seule main fatigué
réseau par des livres ou 7 ça fait
partie d'ailleurs des grands enjeux dans
les pâtisseries savoir qu'elle est
capable de monter conviennent de blom
une seule main ah oui
et paris javier bouteille de vin blanc
des apéritifs comme ça savoir lequel
ça y est maintenant les plus remontés la
super de les serrer un peu
alors là votre père
[Musique]
bon eh bien vous allez travailler qu'à
fait la tournée contre tout mouvement
suspect quartier des gens connaissent
mal tourné passer de la roue dans roue
lanvaux le passé jamais à ces journées
font doucement attend avec la wave est
un très proche devient ici que la
renforcer
mais sérieusement je peux vous dire que
maintenant il faut que l'action je fasse
le plus rapidement possible pour que le
christ je disais que j'allais regarder
si c'est oui je vais regarder six exclus
alors là ce n'est pas je sais que ce
n'est pas tout à fait à ces crimes et
avait offert à la méthode classique
historique les tudors et au confort elle
goûte comme sa hauteur de confiture et
voyez vous on regarde regarde quand
ceux-ci valeo 4 cuil
par conséquent je n'ai pas entendu ce
n'est pas tout à fait ce qui se passait
j'ai ça va les très très riches en
sommes très près de har la conclusion
alors retrouvé son équipe le moi je
m'occupe de ma quantité parce que
lorsque l'on voit très lisse thomson sa
confiture
d'ailleurs il faut le sauver
il faut d'abord savoir où ce carnet de
la gare est consacré je viens maintenant
je crois que liées à l'eau l express
bord revient est à nouveau le feu et
laisser aller ou encore un peu mais là
les vitraux sont les critères définis
sensor et bien voilà catherine je re
avait immédiatement repoussé blanc beur
d'un bénin voilà je vous demanderais qui
peut vous demander simplement avoir à
gand pièce d'éviter que le bois le tout
pendant que les versez le dans la
compilation regroupe les grands partis
sont irrités moral
[Musique]
la voilà la réalité d'obtenir tout
simplement je tiens voilà la file merci
alors là il pourrait receler certes et
l'énergie et vous ça a ajouté beaucoup
[Musique]
préfecture a fait forcément plaît et ça
fait en quelque sorte une sorte de
meringue italienne faire son interview
alors la terre nous avons quelque chose
qui aime bien ces manifs ces
signalements
alors je vais encore la revue un tout
petit peu et puis ils doivent occuper
alors maintenant enfin de faire cette
femme de mousse laurent paru très
patient
[Musique]
en réalité ici je sers encore la main
pour le tout à l'heure à desserrer les
blancs le travail en quelque sorte une
mère de 60 à ce que l'europe veut pas
parce que si je l'avais laissée vous
quand je la remue le diminue un petit
peu de volume actuellement bien le
revient à lui normal il vaut mieux le
faire avant que si ça se fait et une
fraction château
on a un gros gâteau
on sait oui c'est un gâteau en quelque
sorte une mousse comme ceux ci ça finit
par être un gâteau non merci côtés de me
le dire parce que les humains ont
émaillé le petit dévolu bon eh bien ça
ça va peut-être gêné
nous allons retirer le feu est éteint
par conséquent alors ce gâteau il n'est
pas absolument nécessaire mais c'est
néanmoins on peut s'en servir c'est un
fond de jeu noir alors ils n'auraient
pas d'ailleurs tout ça nous allons avoir
une partie est simplement
selon me tuez pas nécessaire sa
direction ne l'a pas on l'a pas on peut
s'en passer
avec ou sans repas
on peut très bien faire la moue sofres
selon mon petit système là sans pour
cela avoir deux fois genoa mais si on a
un poids du noir au milieu du peuple et
moi je crois savoir qu'il s'agit d'une
recette très diverses
il s'agit d'une recette le mans juin
croit totalement vous avez des variants
c'est ça bon et bien une cuillère à
gauche voilà
et on peut le dire alors nous allons
d'abord fixé de leur fixer le le fond
comme ceci avec un petit peu de mousse
n'est ce pas c'est pourquoi que ça bouge
par la suite si nous voulions transporté
alors le fixe comme ceci dit voilà un
petit peu de comscore signalé chinoise
vous mettriez com
s'il n'y avait pas dire loin est-ce que
je mettais de kirsch médias bien sûr que
le mettrais sur les fraises n'est ce pas
être carrément sur les fraises pardon
[Musique]
alors là voyez vous je vais arroser
comme ceci dit il est alors l'homme
essonne serait évident de bélanger ceux
qui recherchent à de sirop du sirop de
sucre pour en quelque sorte économiser
le piège et mieux répartir n'est pas
tandis que l'aja lumineux semblait
d'urgence et aux enseignants avaient
habitués n'ont alors ici voyez-vous avec
une petite écumant comme ceci je mets de
la mousse comme ceux ci dessus
et puis je prends des 13 autres fraises
et ses frais je vais déjà rangé comme
ceux ci haut il n'y a pas besoin de les
découvertes et mettriez-vous en dessous
si avait pas la chinoise je commencerai
c'est ça et puis les frères dessus
mettez ceci son pelage est loin des
chariots même temps
voyez vous comme ça commençait très
sucré je n'hésiterai pas à nouveau
mais comme j'ai déjà mis du kirsch et ne
remettra pas mais tout ça tout ça est
une question de goût si on aime beaucoup
le piège beaucoup le sucre on peut
légèrement à faire des petites variantes
va faire je le conseille pas trop alors
ici à nouveau je fais tout ceci je
remets des fraises petites annonces non
non non non sûrement pas pardon ça
n'était pas volontaire
et puis maintenant ça y est nous allons
pouvoir décorer alors là ça passe à un
autre stade le stade du décor alors
voici la mousse alors très abondante à
ce moment là vous allez voir le l'an
passé coulé non non pas du tout va pas
s'écrouler tout mais je vais le voir
prendre une autre forme pour le moment
là je vous avais
non ainsi je pense à aller prendre un
aspect plus plus spectaculaire walayo
elles soutiennent remarquable oui ça
avait tout juste un peu de confiture de
fraises pas tout à fait
et puis des blancs d'oeuf et vous le
mettez tous au dessus comme ça va
l'emmener ensuite au bord les fascine
toujours avec quatre statuettes avec
décidément vous en servez parce que
toujours c'est indispensable dans un
ménage oui je crois que se tenait un
instrument indispensable des siens en
tête qu'ils ont et au gérant mal et
c'est quand je suis là et voilà on sait
plus du tout c'est cette fois sans
surprise vient c'est très curieux parce
que ça tapait nous foncent et rosé c'est
roger c'est un joli petit reste clair
alors on peut renforcer toujours pareil
la couleur en mai dans la cochenille
l'espagne
la cochenille à quoi je dis c'est une
[ __ ] insectes que l'omb il pourra voir
la couleur c'est une couleur qui est bon
qui s'est justement c'est parce que ce
n'est pas mauvais pour l'affronter pour
le tennis comme colorant cuisine voilà
ça y est vous rêvez maintenant d'en
faire un petit décor m'excuser de
réparation maximum pour que l'on voit
bien bon est ce que vous vous permettez
de prendre ces régimes a répondu cette
fois oui alors voyez vous ce qui se
passe est chaud j'ignore s'il a
peut-être lettre qu'elle était toute à
l'heure très chaud car c'est joli lot
est brûlé
pas chaud c'est pas du tout comment ça
se fait marcher très bien de travers
tous les deux et bien sony fait rien
nous ne pouvons très bien nous en passer
six arrêts marché j'aurais quadrillé
n'est ce pas avec un fer rouge essor
effet un quadrillage très jolie
légèrement à plus foncée mais en fait
c'est par support une catastrophe
nous allons simplement changer notre
méthode décor ce soit un faire comme ça
non on n'a pas ça seulement ce que l'on
peut avoir chez soi très bien c'est en
pic feu que l'on fait rougir dans le
foyer qui avaient chacun une somme louis
bien sûr ne sais pas c'est un devant
l'instrument je suis très étonné je ne
sais pas pourquoi
sinon comment je vais vous laisser
quelque chose comme ça c'est bien voilà
vous allez voir ce que vous allez
changer vite fait on peut très bien
faire au choix des choses simples et un
pic feu rouge alors voyez-vous là pour
décorer comme ceci avec quelques grosses
fraises comme étant m autour et puis
vous allez voir on va réussir
certainement inquiétantes en site oui ça
le puits en même temps c'est très joli
parce que ça fait un cadeau un
quadrillage assez remarquable en fait je
pars c'est pas très embêtant vous allez
voir on va faire reculer lorsque vous
êtes vous faites en ce moment c'est tout
de même livré à la fin des 0 l'as
absolue alors la fin de vie absolue
alors ici les choses alors est-ce que
vous vous servez de fraises particulière
parce que je vois ces fraises elles sont
très grosse
oui mais en réalité on ne se sert pas de
fraises particulier associé à de ce clan
taux sur le marché
bon eh bien maintenant le dos en continu
et en temps trouvant dans ton petit
décor comme ceci cela vous ajoutez les
petites fraises des bois
le petit roeulx des voies de tram n'est
ce pas tout faire j'aime bien aussi je
me suis aussi jolie je ne suis pas un
grand amateur des normes décor la
musique sort seul homme va regarder mais
dans le décor sympathique bond pour ceux
ci s'est terminé alors nous allons donc
je reprends ici
murray restait dans quelque sorte mais
ce n'est pas demain que dans mouche
je prends une poche justement avec m
dites moi si on est moins bon voilà que
vous avez fait un gâteau qui est
présenté
oui tu peux faire vous lui donnez
personnes alors outre divisé par deux
d'ailleurs la proportion de 8,8 blanc et
une livre une fois que la proportion tu
es censé sa prochaine victoire
alors ouais on peut toujours revenu en
arrière bien un fautif difficilement
voilà alors ici vous pouvez laisser le
système mixte en faire sur devant la
caméra si on peut voilà alors faire des
petits trop c'est trop
et la wii a pas intérêt à colorer plus
je trouve pas ce que j'ai vu de
contraste avec les fraises a sûrement
vous avez raison je lis et relis toi
jolie perf est bon dans sa santé alors
ici le on fait également de toute petite
génération qui n'aura pas le gâteau ah
non on avait le regard des gâteaux ne
sont pas faits pour durer longtemps ça
fait je trouve ça dommage parce que le
planter un couteau la dendre est pas là
dedans
le couteau d'accord jugeant ce héros
alors sur chacune ce petit rose art
qu'est ce que vous allez faire des
petites phrases des mobs un petit frère
des voix je récuse savoir ce qu'il ya
dans ce rôle et les téléspectateurs qui
vont refaire cette recette il a rappelé
qu'en même temps d'en bouffer de sa
hauteur et 5 on a pu la notte par
conséquent il faudra alors les
proportions de base sont si vous voulez
pour un kilo de fraises la moitié étant
employé pour la purée et l'autre moitié
pour mettre dedans dans le gâteau n'est
pas vide si on en veut pour le décor est
bien il faudrait en prendre de suite un
kilo de 100 euros pour ceux ses
proportions cinespace environ 8 blonde
jeudi environ lui car selon la grosseur
du jeu se lance on peut aller de 6 à 8
puis c'est aussi selon elle en avait
beaucoup moins quitté titre est
dérisoire satisfait petite fraise des
bois sont facultatives alors vous faites
cuire votre confiture en ayant passé au
préalable les frères il est évident que
vous pourriez cuire les frais
directement dans le sucre et en faire
néanmoins la confiture que vous pourriez
versé sur vos blancs et réussir sans
avoir passé c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas une condition absolument si ces
panneaux non ce n'est pas dupe je sais
pas mais c'est tout de même rêver comme
la mousse dans ses rangs
la relis bien joli et lisse et très bien
fini bon eh bien vous faites donc votre
confiture vous la tenez extrêmement
chaud lorsque les blancs sont montés et
bien ferme comme vous l'avez vu bien
serré pour employés notamment et bien
vous versez dedans et vous obtenez la
mousse que vous pouvez ensuite utiliser
et bien voici j'ai terminé nous avons
notre petit gâteau le voilà notre petit
d'où son frère voilà je la faire tourner
comme ça donc on a pas bien vous croire
que tout les côtés par m
et voilà envoyée c'est un endroit très
facile à faire deux saisons pas cher du
tout et mon dieu j'espère qui sera très
bon lescar pour est serré tout ça enfin
vous aussi d'ailleurs 80 comédiens 6
merci raymond l'hiver la semaine
prochaine à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]